j'aimerais jouer un jeu avec vous et si
vous replonger dans votre enfance
souvenez vous de ce que vous vouliez
être ou devenir plus tard quand je serai
grand je serai que ceux qui ont réalisé
leur rêve d'enfant lèvent le doigt
vous êtes assez nombreux quelle chance
qu'est ce qui fait que nous gardions si
précieusement nos rêves d'enfants nous
en parlons peu pourquoi grandir signifie
t'il renoncer à ses rêves d'enfant je
crois pas je pense au contraire que
grandir c'est s'appuyer sur l'enfant
nous avons été le rêve est un puissant
moteur interne
apprenons à le cultiver je vais vous
raconter une histoire
mon histoire enfant j'avais un rêve
devenir grand reporter mais pas facile
quand on est dyslexique et qu'on a du
mal à prononcer les mots j'ai passé des
heures chez l'orthophoniste à répéter
répéter des syllabes à articuler des
mots a tenté de retenir l'orthographe
mais comment retenir l'orthographe de
contes contes ou compte ou dans la
famille des homonymes les homophones
chaîne ou chaîne ou mieux encore les
homos graff pompom mon livre
d'apprentissage a été pendant de longues
heures
oui oui je me souviens de ces
gribouillis sur les pages pour découper
les mots les hacher en menus morceaux
jusqu'à ce qu'ils libèrent
à donc je vous disais que mon livre
d'apprentissage avait été oui oui donc
j'avais passé des heures à avoir re lire
et à essayer de prononcer des baux
pendant ce temps là mes amis jouaient de
l'autre côté de la cour
je les entends encore c'était le temps
du cochon pendu c'était le temps au big
jim conversait avec barbie mais si je
vous raconte cette histoire c'est parce
que ces heures longues et fastidieuses
ont été bénéfiques
elle monta prise à persévérer et surtout
elles m'ont permis d'accéder à mon rêve
devenir journaliste les enseignants
marque nos années d'enfance
j'ai un souvenir précis de la patience
et de la bienveillance de certains
d'entre eux mais attention les parents
et les enseignants ne sont pas les seuls
à pouvoir aider un enfant
en fait nous sommes tous en mesure de
pouvoir jouer ce rôle un jour c'est ce
qu'on appelle des tuteurs savez vous ce
que signifie tuteur étymologiquement
cela vient de tudor qui veut dire
défenseur protecteur gardien le tuteur
c'est aussi ce que soutient la plante
pendant sa croissance
boris cyrulnik est éloquent sur le sujet
il évoque la capacité de résilience d'un
enfant dès lors qu'ils s'appuient sur
des relations constructives
mes premières années professionnelles au
sein des ong en asie du sud-est auprès
des enfants des rues et de façon plus
proche en france
à vaulx-en-velin montrer remis de
mesurer les bienfaits d'un
accompagnement personnel de l'enfant
j'en ai tiré trois enseignements
le premier laissé l'enfant se construire
son imaginaire autour de ses héros
préférés
il va s'identifier à eux quand je
travaillais pour les éditions jeunesse
j'ai toujours été frappé par le sud
c'est des ouvrages qui parlait
d'explorateurs david livingstone tollé
mais gagarine jean louis etienne
florence arthaud mais aussi des
histoires de petits rats de l'opéra
devenu danseurs ou danseuses ballerine
dans des programmes d'éducation pour des
enfants déscolarisés
j'ai encore vérifié ce propos par tous
les jeunes rêvent l'unicef en a fait
d'ailleurs ça ça sa phrase choc cette
année dans sa campagne
on écrit sur les murs la force de nos
rêves deuxième enseignement
écoutez l'enfant accepter son rythme
c'est se mettre à sa hauteur à sa portée
la prévention routière a développé une
application qui permet à l'adulte de se
mettre à la place est à la hauteur d'un
enfant du don et ceci dans quatre
situations à la sortie de l'école sur le
passage piéton
confronté à un objet sur le trottoir ou
devant une sortie de parking se mettre à
la hauteur de l'enfant à sa portée
troisième enseignement
l'enfant a besoin de cohérence et de
vérité dire avec des mots justes la
vérité aux enfants sur ce qui les
entoure
c'est ce que nous avions essayé de faire
en répondant à des questions d'enfants
que faire quand on voit un sans abri que
deviennent nos rêves quand nous serons
grand mais dire la vérité aux enfants
sur ce qui les entoure
c'est aussi leur faire comprendre les
nuances avec astrapi avec l'unicef et
save the children nous avions développé
un jeu et un ouvrage sur le travail des
enfants du bout du monde
expliquer à nos petits écoliers français
ce que veut dire travailler pour un
enfant du bout du monde
de ces trois enseignements j'ai tiré
trois convictions
la première le rêve est un puissant
moteur interne
le langage est libérateur et l'erreur et
formatrice le rêve est un puissant
moteur interne
j'ai voulu le vérifier en menant une
enquête en juin dernier auprès d'un
panel de connaissances personnelles et
professionnelles j'ai interrogé une
cinquantaine de personnes et le
questionnaire était administré
électroniquement et comportait cinq
questions quel était ton ou tes rêves
avec le recul penses tu qu'ils
exprimaient déçoit futurs as tu réalisé
ton ou tes rêves ou retrouve tu dans ta
vie d'adulte des aspirations d'enfants
quel a été le rôle de l'éducation dans
la réalisation de tes talents voilà ce
qu'il en est sorti beaucoup ont fait de
leurs rêves des croyances positive si
certains parlent de métier d'autres
évoquent plutôt des aspirations
je voulais être autonome je voulais être
libre la quasi-totalité des sondés
considèrent que leurs rêves d'enfants
sont encore présents 50% ont réalisé
leur rêve d'enfant pour les autres
l'objectif reste à atteindre est
atteignable
à la question où on retrouve une ante à
vie d'adulte et aspirations d'enfants la
plupart disent mes aspirations d'enfants
sont là tout proche mes désirs sont tout
près l'éducation a été un levier dans la
réalisation leurs talons mais chose plus
incroyable le rêve relier l'enfant à une
ou plusieurs autres personnes
savez vous que l'étymologie de la joie
en sanskrit c'est le lien la reliance
le rêve devient donc un fabuleux moteur
de joie
le réseau social linkedin a lancé une
large enquête au niveau international
auprès de 8000 salariés pour savoir
quelles étaient les carrières qu'il
voulait occuper plus tard un salarié sur
trois dit occuper aujourd'hui le métier
dont il rêvait enfant fabuleux non
deuxième conviction le langage est
libérateur il permet d'exprimer nos
émotions
mais attention dans l'éducation les mots
peuvent être destructeurs maria
montessori le martelait il faut mieux
parler de maladresse pour une bêtise ou
de besoins pour un caprice troisième
conviction l'erreur est formatrice
je parlerai ici plutôt d'apprentissage
en surmontant mes échecs je gagne en
confiance et je découvre les vertus de
la persévérance
aujourd'hui le monde professionnel tente
de valoriser les chèques
considérant qu'il faut beaucoup d'audace
pour rebondir
41% des français ou peur de l'échec en
cause c'est très nuisible que nous avons
appris pendant l'enfance
il est interdit de se tromper mais il
s'agit pas d'une méthode coué ou je
dirais j'ai le droit de me tromper j'ai
le droit de me tromper
non il s'agit plutôt d'une disposition
interne d'un état d'esprit saisir les
opportunités avec toujours plus
d'entousiasme au risque de me tromper
tels que chess disent les anglais alors
comment aider les enfants à faire ce
difficile exercice de connaissances
personnelles
comment l'aider à découvrir leur
vocation intérieur avec isabelle
artistes et directrice de création
nous voulions chacune à notre manière
elle avec le dessin et moi avec le mot
faire découvrir notre vision deviens ce
que tu es
cette phrase du poète pin d'art qui a
été reprise par nietzsche est
indissociable du connais toi toi même
mais devenir ce que je suis c'est de
venir tout ce que je peux être
c'est me libérer d'une image qui me
colle à la peau ou que d'autres ont
voulu me plaquer avec isabelle on
pensait que le conte c'est wayne 2e
était une bonne façon d'exprimer sa aux
enfants et aux adultes
nous en avons conçu un c'est l'histoire
d'un label ce jeune iront d'eau
n'arrivait pas à chanter il va s'appuyer
sur des tuteurs bienveillant une grande
soeur fiona un maître de choeur le hibou
et petit à petit il va surmonter ses
échecs et réaliser son rêve annoncer le
printemps quand vous avez un rêve il ne
vient pas vous criez au visage voilà ce
que tu es voilà ce que tu dois être
souvent un rêve est presque un
chuchotement
je dis toujours à mes enfants
la chose la plus difficile à écouter
c'est votre instinct votre intuition
personnelle humaine il murmure toujours
il ne crie jamais il est très dur à
entendre
c'est pourquoi vous devez chaque jour de
votre vie est prêt à entendre se murmure
à votre oreille il crie très rarement
et si vous entendez se murmurait qu'il
vous chatouille le coeur et s'il ya
quelque chose que vous pensez devoir
faire pour le reste de votre vie et que
cela devient la chose que vous faites
pour le reste de votre vie alors nous
bénéficierons tous de ce que vous allez
faire comme steven spielberg
je pense que pour apporter au monde pour
devenir un tuteur bienveillant il faut
être aligné sur ses rêves d'enfant